lecture de dossiers législatifs
signature de documents administratifs
appels téléphoniques le quotidien de
fabienne vitaux à 49 ans elle est
assistante parlementaire du député des
yvelines françois de mazières depuis le
début de son mandat
installé dans les bureaux à versailles
elle relaye les demandes des citoyens de
la première circonscription des yvelines
on est en contact constant avec la
circonscription avec les services de
françois de mazières en mairie avec la
préfecture donc en fonction des
sollicitations sur des logements sur des
problèmes d'emploi sur des problèmes de
trafic de réseau sncf qui ne fonctionne
pas ces sujets qui interpellent les
administrés fabienne s'occupe de la
communication sur le web
pour elle c'est une vocation elle ne
compte pas ses heures de travail
c'est passionnant c'est vraiment
passionnant mais c'est passionnant aussi
parce que parce que c'est un député qui
donnent la main qui fait confiance et
une fois que la confiance était à 12
heures c'est du bonheur c'est votre
proposition de loi sur la nature
donc ça fait pas courir après une
rémission ça est ce que vous faites est
cosigné mais ils n'ont pas confirmé sa
très gros travail de préparation
d'abord d'examen de toutes les
propositions d'amendement de textes qui
nous arrive est très régulièrement
et puis ensuite on manque un an j'ai
pris pour l'opposition le spécialiste
questions culturelles que je suis très
souvent intervenu dans les débats par
l'animateur
comment alors les uns présentation des
budgets l'autre volet de son activité se
déroule ici dans les bureaux de
l'hémicycle fabienne vitaux y consacrent
une grande partie de son temps de
travail
originaire de franche-comté elle passe
son baccalauréat et devient secrétaire
médicale elle reprend des études de
droit public obtient le niveau d ea et
décide de rentrer dans l'administration
j'ai souhaité me consacrer en fait aux
services publics parce que j'ai toujours
voulu travailler pour l'intérêt général
et donc j'ai passé différents concours
administratifs et j'ai obtenu celui
enfin un concours pour entrer au
secrétariat général du gouvernement donc
être à la disposition des premiers
ministres servir les autres c'est
essentiel et travailler pour l'état pour
moi c'est important et au travers de
françois de mazières aujourd'hui je
considère que je continue à travailler
pour l'état
elle a notamment travaillé au cabinet du
premier ministre
occasion pour elle de rencontrer
françois de mazières alors conseiller
communication et culture auprès du chef
du gouvernement
c'est le début de leur collaboration
fabienne devient ensuite son assistante
parlementaire à l'assemblée nationale
sa principale tâche ici faciliter le
travail du parlementaire pour ses prises
de parole en commission ou en séance
publique dans toutes ses interventions
en commissions culture on lui prépare
des notes des éléments de langage
nous voyons sur l'actualité au quotidien
pour l'informer et il nous revient aux
amours françois de mazières a décidé de
ne pas briguer un nouveau mandat de
parlementaire
fabienne restera sa collaboratrice pour
une autre mission sinon elle retournera
à matignon pour poursuivre sa vocation
servir l'état